well you search what is one of the most
fascinating things to me I have looked
up to the sky from the time I was really
young and just
like it's the only it's a thing that
gives me a headache because I think it
goes on for Infinity but then what's at
the end of there's nothing it goes it
keeps going there must be an end but
what would that be and is that like what
you used to think when you were a kid
when you looked up to the sky now when I
looked up to the sky as a kid I looked
up and I thought one of those Stars
there's going to be a planet and there's
going to be some little kid on that
planet walking along with their parent
and seeing
seeing our star in their Sky our son as
a star in their sky and they're going to
be wondering whether anybody is up there
looking at them I agree with you I I my
opinion being that there's no way we're
alone like it's there's way too much
it's an awful waste of space are those
actually your words
[Music]
they're the screenwriters was the scene
of you walking with your dad in the
movie part of your part of your
contribution or because when you said
that that's immediately what I thought
is that that was a scene in the movie
yes yeah that's really cool how did that
even come about that's so interesting I
think we just got a phone call I Know
Carl was writing the book I told Carl
about this experience that I'd had just
after I got my PhD I went to a meeting
in Washington I think it was the
American Association of women in science
that's sponsored it anyway I walked into
a room full of 80 women 80 really smart
clever women and it just was a
life-changing event having been the only
woman in 300 of my engineering class
I had just gotten used to walking into
rooms full of men walking into this room
full of women who were all bright and
smart and
talented it was spectacular we
swapped stories of how we managed to
make it through the pipeline when so
many others didn't many of the women
overwhelming number of the women their
dads were the biggest influence in their
life and that was my case right
unfortunately my dad died
when I was young he died when I was 12.
one of the things I learned from that
was this Carpe Diem idea you know don't
put off asking a question of your father
till tomorrow because he might not be
there
and it's amazing how many of the other
women had the similar kind of experience
were there questions that you wish you
would have asked oh sure infinite number
how do I make it through this life
I deal with yeah all the challenges that
will be coming right I didn't know
enough dance you have to ask those then
I mean you know you say that and how do
you make it through this life and you
know there's a lot of esoteric thoughts
that go through my mind and people I
speak to and I don't know if that is the
same for you but so many people will
reply with I don't want to come back
next time next time around I'm not doing
this it's too hard do you believe in
that sort of idea that you come back
again I don't think so I but I don't
have any scientific data to support it
or refute it it just doesn't seem to be
um a mindset that is comfortable for me
is that is that represent is that true
how scientifically based you are with
everything that you believe in is that
it really does need to come down to
science is that is that the real you
yeah that's what I'm comfortable with
yes I mean truly my my favorite part in
the movie as
the scene of asking to prove love for
your dad and I really like that was just
such a I never forgot that scene
um so how would you explain love then I
mean I'm just might as well ask you you
know if you can't prove love how do you
know but it still exists right it exists
and I don't know why you have to prove
it
um it's an emotion that sometimes you're
lucky enough to be able to experience
and share and therefore
it's an emotion it isn't science
um
so I don't know why you don't just
appreciate it and live with it does that
not apply then when it comes to the
question of are we alone and that can
you just believe it without proof no the
are wheel question requires uh an
extraordinary amount of evidence to be
able to a infer that that's what you've
that you've found evidence for someone
else's technology that's what we're
trying to do
and be then interpret that evidence and
using a lot of other expertise that I
don't particularly have but I think if
that problem were posed there would be
no lack of individuals and organizations
who would try to figure out what it was
that we were actually finding 2016 I
think it was where there were multiple
claims of detection of extraterrestrial
intelligence there were much better
explanations for each of the claims in
the end
and I've been since then sort of on a
hobby horse
reminding people that back in the 80s at
the International Academy of
astronautics and The International
Institute of Space law we developed a
set of principles
um
regarding actions following the
detection of extraterrestrial
intelligence and really keep trying to
remind people
of those principles and how how to do a
search and how to get confirmation of
what you've found and how to tell the
world and I think if I recall back in
the 80s the the motivation for
constructing this set of principles was
the fact that our Soviet colleagues
in the former Soviet Union we're doing
study searches we were concerned that if
they should be successful they would be
prevented from sharing that information
so we developed this set of principles
and one of the things that says number
eight is you know make sure that you
know what you've got and then tell the
world when you think about this
and you think about the technology that
we have now
which we didn't have in the 1980s there
are better ways of searching ways of
searching that lend themselves to
confirmation and verification and
validation oh really
um like using two telescopes and finding
the same thing in both telescopes with
three time delays between them
um
so that's
that's sort of where I'm spending my
time and effort now that and trying to
build an endowment
because we now
deeply understand that this may be a
multi-generational
search effort and so it might be my
great granddaughter that succeeds
eventually in finding evidence of
someone else's technology right so we
have to find a way to keep not huge
amounts of funding but at least
Dependable funding year upon year
generation after generation and of
course universities figured out how to
do that Millennia though
that's a big undertaking it is but it's
worth it I mean yeah you always want the
best and the brightest right people to
be joining you and you always have to
recruit your Replacements and so the
recruiting job is is somewhat difficult
because you can't promise success and
most young scientists and Engineers want
to say well in my career I'm going to do
X Y and Z and I'm going to be well
rewarded and famous for that and of
course I can't say that in fact I have
to say hmm well yeah you can make it
famous but I'm not sure I can make
payroll at the end of the month
and they're like how much of a passion
project is this if you do you really
believe that there is life out there it
actually doesn't matter what I believe
right this is science and so it matters
what I can prove if I told you I knew
the answer that would be religion and
not science so what I believe doesn't
matter what I can find through
scientific exploration and does matter
what do you want to find
well it's a big question and I'd like to
know
what other ways there are to make a
biology and to make a technology or is
us and what happened here the only way
it can manifest
seems unlikely
don't know the answer to that right we
can we can look and now I mean our tools
are getting better all the time we're
building bigger telescopes we're
building all kinds of spacecraft for
exploration
um I know we we've got the Rovers on
Mars that are caching
Rock samples to be picked up later and
to be showing that really earlier on
Mars was wet and warm and salty Wow
might have been a place where life could
get started I interviewed Brian Cox he
thought that by taking core samples from
Mars that maybe it would leave it would
give us some kind of understanding as to
how we came about
and my question was it might have just
come about just the way that we're going
to Mars and taking a core sample that
like life came from somewhere else and
went oh let's just see what's going on
over here and that it seems like the
most likely most likely scenario that it
happened just the same
well that's that that idea is often
called panspermia that life came from
somewhere else and seated uh life here
and what would not necessarily disprove
but at least make less likely that story
would be if we found a biology that was
totally independent from Life as we know
it I mean all life that we currently
know is related right based on the same
kind of biology and
um molecular coding if we found a
totally independent
biology then that would make it less
likely that were clones of or seeds from
someplace else
[Music]